that's a nice dress
thank you I like your jacket
Thanks flights on time
it is great I'm sorry what was that what
you just took a step forward there I did
yeah you did you know you did and if
what's funny is there's no way you can
board first because the only way you
could board first is to be a special
name do you have a special need yes I
need to be over there what brings you so
close and going to that destination
wedding tell her to keep it so we're
just the people you don't know how to
stick you might as well just stick us
together I don't want to be a person you
don't know where to stick doesn't issue
what is presumptuous there in a fool's
paradise you believe there's someone for
everyone close I believe that there's
nobody for anyone
I understand how even after Keith did
what he did to you can possibly still be
mooning over because you're a monkey who
doesn't understand the human condition
having met you I understand why it's a
condition
you know I'm not wearing anything maybe
JA why would you they're so alluring
[Music]
what is that I think it's a mountain
lion could it be a Jaguar what
difference does it make mm-hmm the
Cougar maybe Jesus course
[Music]
how do you not install a pathway the
heels won't make it please carry me
please what carried
[Music]
you
[Music]
you